hi this is james franco and i'm here
with film courage calm i'm talking to
Karen worden and David Brannon we're
going to talk about this palo alto
stories campaign on indiegogo thank you
so much for listening i think what a lot
of people don't grasp about crowdfunding
is that it has so much to do with
marketing and your team has done a
wonderful job with the updates you know
keeping people informed and these these
quick videos from you just you know sort
of dipping your toe and this
crowdfunding water what have you seen
has been successful in terms of
generating buzz about it and and what do
you think maybe you'll do differently
next time I realize the campaign's still
going on I don't know I just gotta do
what they tell me you know I the only
reason I'm doing the crowdfunding way
because I'm asking for the money for
myself all of the profits absolutely not
dollar one over to charity and because i
just i know that you know studios or you
know finance companies aren't one to
give my fellow grad students chances
like this and so forth in the past i've
been to one to help finance or I found
financing another way that I you know
been given favors by very very generous
favors by actors like Natalie Portman
and Jessica Chastain and Kristen Wiig
and we'll all acted in these projects
alerted to get funding for the students
but but it's still very hard and so that
those are the main reason that I turned
to the crime funny as far as how to run
in campaign I I just do what they say
and I
try to keep people over there what we're
doing and why I think this is important
that you know there's clearly not
something I'm you know just doing for
myself it's for others in many many ways
what was it about these three or four
artists that you are working with that
made you decide to collaborate what what
did you see in them that major arms yeah
I mean I you know I went to school with
all of them and they they just you know
they're the ones that you know we're
either but the hardest workers had you
know visions that I respected and and
then also you know a little bit of
casting you don't even want to just let
cat only won't fit my actor to the
character you know I thought that they
all had the right sensibilities for
these these pieces so it was just
combination of all those things
you